25 لاعبا من المنتخب الفرنسي سيشاركون في
بطوله كاس العالم في قطر مدرب المنتخب
اعلن عن ضم الهداف اوليفياجيو الى القائمه
ويقدم المهاجمون الذي عاد لتشكيله فرنسا
في مارس ادري الماضي بعد غياب دم تسعه
اشهر اداء جيدا في الفتره الاخيره الشيء
الذي اقنع ديشون
في اختياراتك بل هو تقييم للوضع هناك
اشياء تقرر عن طريق النقاش كما فعلت مع
اوليفي والاعبين اخرين وما جعلني افكر
واتخذ القرار هم العناصر الموجوده داخل
وخارج الملعب
وضمه تشكيله التي يتقدمها قائد ريال مدريد
الاسباني كريم بنزيما افضل لاعب في العالم
هذا العام 11 لاعبا من المتزوجين بلقب
العالمي في النسخه الاخيره في روسيا في
مقدمتهم مبابي وكريسمان
نحن في امان
وبنزيما
على العديد من ركائزه في الهجوم
قدمها المدرب الجديد